hmmm dayquil what's up everyone I'm
Ilana and welcome to my channel
right now I'm in Anaheim for PSX 2017
and that's what this video is going to
be a vlog of all of the cool PSX
adventures that await me and my very
sick throat I actually flew down to LA
yesterday though for the Game Awards
it's my first time going to the game
woods I have been to the GDC all woods
before but never the game Awards
that was really cool some awesome
announcements super stoked about Soul
Calibur about Bayonetta 3 link getting a
motorbike was a real highlight it's fun
fact about the death stranding trailer I
predicted it I said that I thought that
we were going to get a trailer and a guy
on Facebook said there wouldn't be and I
said I would bet him $50 that we would
have a trailer and he has not responded
and actually I hoped awaiting his
comment I see you you owe me 50 bucks
pay up son so that parts done tonight
was gotten fancied less fancy than I was
yesterday but tonight is the PlayStation
experience conference not expecting
major announcements out of this one all
right so um I'm ready let's go
[Music]
I'm very excited I hope that there's a
Bradburn and I hope Crash Bandicoot is
either it's I'm very tired
I need information to determine first
thing try now welcome back to the hotel
from the conference which was pretty
much exactly what I expected they want
any release dates all major
announcements and up to the Paris games
week I just wasn't expecting that to
happen so no surprises there for me I
have a lot of people tweeting at me
saying that they disappointed but I I've
been saying for months you guys but
literally months that I didn't think
this show was it was either not going to
happen art wasn't gonna be very big so
I'm not disappointed at all so I'm
heading back to the hotel now I'm gonna
get some food and then go to sleep early
because I am very sick and we have a big
day tomorrow so yeah see you guys
tomorrow morning good morning everyone
I'm just finished getting ready and it
is time for day one proper of PSX we
have an IGN panel where we're ranking
the top ten PlayStation games of all
time like just as kind of a fun thing
and I'm a little bit worried about my
voice so we'll see how that progresses
when I'm like actually in the convention
set of meeting people it's gonna be
rough but my first goal get coffee
obviously and then my second goal is to
go check out a bunch of indie games and
PS VR games things that I wouldn't
normally have access to I may not have
heard off before so let's get to it
I made it to the show floor it's
actually super chill there's a lot more
open space than I expected but first up
I'm going to play inpatient Fiat which
is just some bit delayed and I'm also
going to play go loss Katya vo demo
which comes out on Tuesday which I'm
pretty excited about as one of my Jam's
like biggest VI fans I haven't seen a
ton of Indies around so I'm still gonna
try and seek some of those out but I did
just make appointments for Detroit
become human for the car demo and also
for guacamelee to which I'm pretty
excited about so I'm gonna be playing
dogs later today before the panel and
yeah I think a lot of my day today is
just gonna be like meeting people who
watch the stuff that I make which is the
best so we are now heading it to the
panel wow this guy it's in the main
arena that there only is one and Andrew
was just saying how he's very nervous
that we are going to be able to fill it
out because if it's like 4500 people
it's gonna be all righty so a backstage
right now getting ready for the panel
Montillo hosted how you feel yes I feel
very good I'm the only one who knows the
10 games we're talking which is exciting
we all submitted them to you yeah you
submitted to a couple and I paired it
onto to and so I'm the only no but one
who knows who defend our and they're
very strange all right think I think
you're gonna have a couple controversial
ones oh I'm definitely gonna have a
controversial one it's gonna be exciting
it's like almost objectively not yeah
but it's one that will be fun to talk
about Matt in 2013 Matt 2013 okay I
found us thoughts in three minutes
we have finally walking out all of us
have our microphones on from the way
that the conference with last night I'm
actually pretty excited to get to walk
down this like cool light-up stance so
it should be fun let's do the thing
[Music]
I feel my bottom
[Music]
we don't weigh less couches than they
have well yeah the sofa how's everyone's
PSF how's it been so far seems alright
beautiful he proposed for the listing
you just said he wouldn't fight forget
one with a K alright
somepony thank you all nice panel was so
much fun thank you so much to everyone
who came I'm rushing back to the media
room right now to play my Detroit demo
I'm gonna explore a little bit of the
show floor after that and then head back
to the hotel to actually write the
preview alrighty you back at the hotel
I'm gonna start writing on my Detroit
preview I'm basically talking about my
current headline is how Detroit become
human handles domestic abuse in-game
very serious theme that I really wanted
to talk about my pieces effectively
about how the car demo which deals with
child abuse in my opinion deals with it
in a mature and and smart way that
doesn't just like glorify violence so
trivialize it or anything like that so
this is gonna be a pretty like heavy
thing for me to write but I'll do it and
then send it off to people to edit and
then I'm gonna go I'm gonna go eat some
ice cream because my throat hurts and I
want some dessert and then I think a
couple people going to the bar across
the road so I'll probably had that for a
little bit but try not to drink too much
because I'm just gonna keep getting more
sick writing is done you guys I'm ready
to go out I actually changed into this
adorable
Totoro Scott that I absolutely love and
having one before and it's warm in LA so
I can Wescott's now they get to do that
in San Francisco so I'm matches my
tattoo obviously so I'm going to go to
the hotel bar now and then I have an
appointment for dreams tomorrow morning
which I am crazy excited about let's go
all righty you guys I'm heading out for
day 2 right now I'm going straight to a
dreams appointment wearing another very
cute outfit today let me take you to the
mirror it's this adorable spaceship
dress
[Music]
[Music]
so I just wrapped up the
behind-closed-doors of dreams and what
an incredible game basically you can do
anything I'm gonna try and make a horror
game and then I'm gonna try and make a
bunch of music and like music videos in
it um it's such impressive self-aware
that I could ramble about forever but
I'm sure I'll talk about it don't know
shows at IGN over the next few weeks so
I'm gonna walk around the show floor
meet more people because that's been the
bulk of the show and try and get some of
the collectible cards that they have
here they have these um limited edition
PSX cards I've been getting decks of
every year so I'm gonna check some of
those out and yeah
[Music]
[Music]
all righty that is it for PSX 2017
definitely saw some cool stuff on the
show floors but I have to say it is
mostly boots like the media who've
already seen everything at e3 it's a
little bit weird it's definitely more of
a show for fans and I'm also totally
cool with that I met so many cool people
kind of need that every now and then
when you walk on the internet and people
out [ __ ] and then you come to an
event like this and you're like oh
people aren't all off so hopes people
are nice so yeah it was super cool I
have another vlog coming later this week
Stahl was related so you guys could
should keep an eye out for that one and
I will see you next time